Nia Long and ineudoka are going their
separate ways
he confirms the couple have officially
split following months of speculation
about their relationship status he's a
coach in the NBA how do you guys work
everything out a lot of patience Nia and
IMEI were together for 13 years and they
share 11 year old son kez
and the News comes as they navigate The
Fallout of the NBA coach's cheating
scandal back in September their
relationship was thrown into the
spotlight the investigation had some
twists and turns and took some time to
develop all the facts eme was accused of
engaging in
a member of the boss
breaking the franchise's code of conduct
we will make a determination at a later
time about email's future with us in the
end he was suspended for the entire
season emei offered a public apology
quote I am sorry for putting the team in
this difficult situation and I accept
the team's decision he added quote I
want to apologize to our players fans
the entire Celtics organization and my
family for letting them down and I think
we have to ask ourselves are we a part
of the problem or are we a part of the
solution Aunt Nia she broke her Silence
by sharing this cryptic clip to
Instagram
as that light that you see you know you
see the happiness but understand one
thing about that light that they got
they had to go into the darkness to get
it Mia later told E.T in a statement
quote the outpouring of love and support
from family friends and the community
during this difficult time means so much
to me above all I am a mother and will
continue to focus on my children
everybody has to Define their
relationship for themselves especially
when you're both working and you have
busy schedules fast forward over two
months later Nia slamming the Boston
Celtics speaking with The Hollywood
Reporter the actress says the most
heartbreaking moment came when she saw
kez's face after the basketball team's
president as Nia puts it quote decided
to make a very private situation public
and to escape the media blitz Nia
reveals she took kez out of school quote
it was devastating he still has moments
where it's not easy for him you can be a
working mom be there for your kids and
still be the artist that you are Nia
also says she's leaving Boston to move
to LA with kez and Psy her son from a
previous relationship women are super
women but we also have to recharge our
batteries I've learned especially in
this covet time to really examine how
I'm balancing my work home life in a
different way animate the Scandal Nia
claims no one from the Celtics has ever
quote called to see if I'm okay to see
if my children are okay it's very
disappointing
[Music]
thank you